we're continuing our trip down memory
lane talking milestones and memories are
we ready for more
it's 1980. phil and marlo get married
and you guys met actually in 1977 is
that correct
on phil's talk show we just clicked
right off we clicked on his show it was
obvious
that we we were very attracted to each
other and
i just loved his confidence he just you
know he
knew what he was doing and he and i was
on a a tour for a movie
so i did his show in chicago and then uh
i was moving to the next city and he got
a hold of where i was and
and asked me if denver was very far from
chicago and i said oh no
not very far at all and so he came to
denver
and we had dinner and and that was it i
mean really
and i've been living in hollywood for my
whole life
i had not met people like phil that were
more like my family
um middle class values midwest
my dad was from toledo my husband's from
cleveland um
it we we just looked i mean it was like
i met somebody from my own tribe
oh gosh swoon
is there something that you guys do for
each other
or do with each other that maybe we
don't know about
well you know you were talking about our
podcast
um the podcast was
to be clear as to answer your question
was really
we wanted to find out why it was that
our marriage lasted
when we saw other friends who who were
falling apart
some of them some of our friends like
alan alda and arlene alden
and several others lenny pogba and her
husband burt have been together
60 years billy crystal 50 years
how does that happen and we kind of
wanted to know that
because people kept asking us what's
your secret sauce and we thought
we don't know what it is we love each
other we like each other
but what is it who said the
make to make a marriage last you should
sleep
tushy to tushy so
i mean we got a lot of good advice
judith for yours but what we learned as
we traveled around the country
on these double dates was that
people who made it both people right
wanted marriage both people wanted the
marriage now you see in some
relationships
where one person is sort of dragging it
along and making it work and
making all the accommodations but in a
marriage it lasts a long time
both people want it both people fight
for it whether it means marriage
counseling or whatever
and nobody's looking for the exit signs
yeah and that is a
that may sound simple-minded but boy
it's tough
and this is a perfect segue to 2021
and your podcast double date
um i'm so excited about this podcast
that you have you have extraordinary
guests on
wonderful couples who have figured out
that secret sauce as you call
it um the list is impressive i mean it's
sting and trudy styler and viola davis
and neil patrick harris and john mcenroe
and all of these interesting people
bob woodward that ali you know wentworth
i'm like these are the voices i'd really
love
to hear from coming at it
with different perspectives james
carville alan alda
i want to hear what they have to say
about a lasting marriage
and you know what's important drew uh we
talked a lot about
fighting you know how you fight and how
you come back from a fight
but the i think the thing that we
thought when we
got off the road aside from the fact
that nobody looked for an exit sign
and that they were all in as kira
sedgwick said there is no plan b
but the other thing we notice is that
people make the accommodations for each
other
phil and i are completely different and
after 40 years i realized
that no matter how hard i try he is
never going to be me
and no matter how hard he tries i'm
never going to be him
so you have to make the accommodation
for the other person and realize
you love that person so let them be let
them be free to me
let them be who they are and that takes
a while because
when people first get together they
think oh i'll change that about him and
i'll get her to stop doing that
and as uh john mcno's wife patty smythe
who's just a knockout
she said women marry potential she said
forget it
there is no potential marry who you see
it's not going to become it's not going
to bloom in to another person that you
might rather have
and she said so many of her girlfriends
say i know he doesn't look like my type
now
but he's got great potential she said
walk away walk right away
and i think that that's another thing to
really think about
you know before you get married is be
sure that it's
um it's it's what exactly that person is
who you want
and allie wentworth and george
stephanopoulos are the cutest couple
you would never put them together i mean
i would never have fixed them up and i
love to fix people up
but you know george is his statesman
he's very you know all
buttoned up and she's just this wild
wonderful funny thing
and she loves to talk about sex and he
goes
you know it's it it's adorable and and
we asked her well what's your advice
about sex and she said have it
and have a lot of it and she
just i just love her i love what you
said that patty smythe said about don't
marry potential
that is a real pipe dream and you're
right people should not try to change
each other
they should try to change and grow in
life
but not change each other and i i
couldn't agree more
[Music]